welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and Spider-Man
across the spider-verse officially
introduced us to the Web of Life and
Destiny or the arachno humanoid poly
Multiverse as Miguel O'Hara prefers to
call it and while we'll have to wait at
least a year or more if they keep
underpaying and disrespecting creatives
to finish miles's Trilogy we might
actually see the web of life and Destiny
sooner than later Sony's Madame Web
movie is set for release in February
2024 and while we don't have a ton of
details about it just yet Madame Webb as
a character is tailor-made to explore
the web of life and Destiny and through
it she could further tie together the
MCU and Sony spiderverse it is usually a
good idea to have a seat when your world
is about to be turned upside down after
releasing 2018's Venom 2021 Venom Let
There Be Carnage and 2022's morbius
brownie is doubling down on their
Spider-Man adjacent properties with
their first female-led spin-off starring
Dakota Johnson as The titular character
Madame Webb written by morbius writers
Matt sazama and Burke sharpless Madam
Webb is going to be a different kind of
movie in this universe according to
producer Lorenzo di bonaventura at least
in an interview with comicbook.com di
bonaventura said that the film is more
of a thriller than an action picture and
that's because Madame Webb's skill set
isn't conducive to an action piece
because comic book Madame Webb's past is
shrouded in mystery the bonaventura said
that they're taking advantage of this to
make a new origin story for the iconic
Clairvoyant Debona Ventura also says
that the film will introduce us to the
character before she becomes the
character we know from the comics and
we'll get to see how she becomes that
person first hand Sony has yet to
confirm the civilian identity of their
Madame web and the comics actually have
two different Madam webs to choose from
set photos show Dakota Johnson wearing a
costume similar to the one the second
Madame web Julia Carpenter wears but
there are also rumors that Sydney
Sweeney will be the one playing Julia
Carpenter not Johnson if those rumors
end up being true this would make
Johnson a much younger Cassandra Webb
and seems to fit with Debona Ventura
wanting to explore the early life of the
character in the comics Cassandra Webb
made her Marvel debut in 1980s The
Amazing Spider-Man issue number two 10
the prophecy of Madame web Webb is a
mutant who has both precognitive and
Clairvoyant abilities and is depicted as
an older blind woman who suffers from a
neuromuscular disease called myasthenia
gravis her disability makes it necessary
for her to stay connected to a life
support system that looks like a giant
spider web which is how she gets her
moniker most of Webb's early appearances
involved her using her psychic powers to
predict villainy giving Spider-Man a
heads up on criminal activity and
disasters the character eventually found
popularity thanks to the 90s animated
series voiced by Stanley's wife Joan Lee
this version of Webb wasn't a mutant
instead she was Rewritten as a powerful
Cosmic being from another universe who
even Dr Strange knew not to F around
with what's wrong I sense that we
watched by someone whose Powers dwarf my
own in the series Madame Webb looks into
the future and sees the destruction of
the Multiverse and basically all reality
at the hands of Spider Carnage a former
Spider-Man who's merged with one of the
Carnage symbiotes Reb sets out to test
all the different Spider-Man variants to
see which one will be capable of saving
the Multiverse this version of web
intertwined the character with the
concept of the Marvel Multiverse
influencing her future depictions across
media and making web psychic powers stem
from a connection to the Web of Life and
Destiny that holds the fabric of the
Multiverse together its secret Invasion
season and the easiest way to let people
know that you're not a scroll or make
them think you're not a scroll is to
pick up some merch From Nerd Riot's new
secret Invasion collection the
shapeshifter P announces that you're
totally an out of scroll which is
exactly what a scroll shirt would say
the Friend or Foe and the one last fight
shirts highlighter buds Roadie and Nick
Fury and their potential to really be a
green skin alien we can also shop our
full line of designs inspired by Across
the spiderverse and Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 and keep an eye out for a
very cool Barbie Oppenheimer combo shirt
that is officially the best thing to
wear on your torso in July shopping at
nerd Riot is one of the best ways to
support our channel so join the riot
over at nerd riot.shop be it the
Spider-Man animated series or games like
Spider-Man Shattered Dimensions Webb has
garnered a reputation of becoming a
multiversal spider recruiter akin to
mcu's Nick Fury so it's very likely that
Sony will be using their Madame web film
to build out a story that'll serve as a
launching point for crafting an
interconnected story that explores the
Multiverse a Multiverse that has already
been shown in no way home and across the
spider-verse to have connections with
the MCU by the looks of what little
images we have of the film thus far
Madame love will have already started
recruiting some spiders without going
too deep into unsubstantiated rumor
territory Madame Webb will likely
feature three separate spider women as I
said earlier Sydney Sweeney is
potentially playing Julia carpenter
carpenter is the second Spider Woman who
inherits Madame Webb's powers and
becomes the second Madame web when
Cassandra dies then we have Celeste
O'Connor rumored to be playing Maddie
Franklin the third Spider Woman and
niece of Jay Jonah Jameson and lastly we
have Isabella Merced reportedly playing
Anya Corazon a spider girl who also goes
by the Alias aranya now this might sound
like too many spiders to be true but the
possibility of Sony's Madame web putting
this lineup together is very reminiscent
of a late 90s Spider Woman in Spider
Woman volume 3 issue 1 a youthfully
rejuvenated Madame web puts together a
team of three spider women to hunt down
a fort Madame Webb's own granddaughter
Charlotte Witter now this team does
differ slightly from the film's rumored
roster instead of aranya the comic
feature Jessica drew the first Spider
Woman rumors also suggest that the
reasoning for this team up will be much
different than this comic run with
Webb's spider team forming to protect
Emma Roberts character who may or may
not be May Parker Peter's mother these
parallels to Spider-Woman volume 3 have
me personally convinced that Dakota
Johnson will most likely play a youthful
Cassandra Webb and Sydney Sweeney will
play Julia Carpenter who will be set up
at some point to inherit Webb's Powers
title and possibly even her killer
wardrobe if this is direction that Sony
is headed it does tie in with both
Craven the Hunter and potential future
plans for the web of life and Destiny in
the arc known as the Grim hunt Craven's
family hunt down spider heroes in an
effort to revive their father part of
this is the killing of Cassandra who in
her last moments bestows her powers to
Julia Carpenter as the new Madam Webb
Julia's comic arcs deal heavily with
protecting the order of the web of life
and Destiny judging by the Craven
trailer we aren't likely to get Craven's
whole Pride introduced but Sony is
packing in several potential allies for
the hunter Calypso the Rhino and
Craven's half-brother the chameleon are
featured prominently in the trailer my
thoughts are that we're seeing a decent
lineup for the Sinister Six if you add
in morbius and vulture and if they're
little Cliffside Meetup is any
indication we might be heading towards a
spider hunt a spider hunt that could
draw inspiration from the Grim hunt if
Madame Webb introduces a handful of
spiders like the rumor suggests we could
see a clash between the two parties that
results in Julia Carpenter becoming the
new Madame web remember ultra's
appearance in Morpheus and Venom's
Universe hop hints that doctor strange
and Peter one's actions no way home have
Tangled portions of the web of life and
Destiny rearranging variants or people
connected to Peter Parker across
Dimensions I wouldn't be surprised if
the events of Madame Webb and Craven
reveal that even more universes have
become Tangled so a grim hunt for spider
Heroes might lead to some grave
multiversal repercussions just like the
consequences of averting Cannon events
and across the spider-verse what happens
when two foreign variants affect fight
or die in a cannon that isn't their own
a domino effect could destabilize the
Multiverse and what's the best solution
for fixing this having Madame Webb with
her multiversal powers go directly to
the source of her woes Tom Holland's
Peter Parker um hi
Sony has expressed interest in diving
further into the Multiverse to
potentially do a live-action
spider-verse storyline Sony's also
shamelessly tried to find a way to work
in connections with the MCU so if
they're going multiversal they'll
undoubtedly try to tie in Tom Holland's
Peter and considering that he's the
reason for the Multiverse being amiss in
the first place it would only make sense
now if it'll happen we'll certainly be
up to how effectively Sony and Disney
negotiate about the use of Tom Holland
but if across the spiderverts in no way
home or any indication mashing up
Spider-Man cannons is a Surefire way to
print money and Sony loves money follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at Whitney
pup you follow me rockstars subscribe to
me rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign